je passe au 1689 qui le défend oui nos
employés
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre donc je défends cet amendement
sur le sujet donc des entrées de ville
amendement plusieurs fois défendu par
notre collègue jean pierre sueur cet
amendement s'inscrit pleinement dans une
logique de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols en voulant
agir dans les zones souvent délaissée
que l'on appelle les entrées de ville
dans cette perspective l'amendement
propose que les documents d'urbanisme
assure la préservation des sols et la
qualité urbaine architecturale et
paysagère des entrées de ville merci
avis la commission
ce président la solution proposée dans
cet amendement ne paraît pas opérante
il prévoit que le pndd fixer les
conditions d'aménagement est entré à la
destination des bâtiments la surface
dédiée au stationnement
les zones à réhabiliter ou encore des
proportions des espaces verts or dans
les pays et lui le pead est l'aîné fixe
que des orientations très générale n'est
pas directement opposables aux permis et
aux autorisations à mon sens ce que
propose cet amendement a davantage sa
place selon le règlement de paix et lui
ou dans des zoos happé par permis de
proposer les mesures proposées en
matière de stationnement des espaces
verts aux destinations le règlement il
ya déjà outillés pour cela je comprends
donc la symbolique
cet amendement en partager l'esprit mais
en l'état je suis défavorable à part car
pas au pérou à vis du gouvernement
madame la ministre je crois que la
réglementation actuelle elle permet déjà
aux opérations d'aménagement et de
programmation d'établir des dispositions
prescriptif pour traiter de ce sujet le
rôle d'ailleurs il sera renforcé par
plusieurs articles du projet de loi
notamment l'article 49b idées pour
traiter des franges urbaines et les
dispositions relatives à
l'artificialisation notamment ce
moratoire commerciale qui est défini à
l'article 52 inciteront les
collectivités à repenser l'aménagement
des entrées de ville et puis viendra
s'ajouter au dispositif déjà en place
pour permettre la version urbaine et
paysagère des aménagements en entrée de
ville on pense évidemment aux
autorisations d'exploitation commerciale
aux autorisations de revitalisation des
territoires et de petites villes de
demain
en outre je crois que le projet
d'aménagement et de développement
durable des pme
ne peut pas établir de dispositions
prescriptive qui s'imposeraient aux
autorisations d'urbanisme tels que
l'amendement les proposent c'est donc un
avis défavorable
merci sur le 1689 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté le 2088 monsieur marchand
oui monsieur le président dans la
continuité de l'amendement de 1097
défendu précédemment cet amendement
souhaite reconnaître lors de la votation
des faits lui les enjeux et la
complémentarité des territoires ruraux
afin de garantir un développement
équilibré de leur territoire une telle
mention permettra d'encourager une
mutualisation des objectifs de
consommation des espaces au sein
d'appeler lui sans pénaliser les
communes rurales dans la répartition de
ces objectifs est de tenir compte de
leurs besoins
merci à vis de la commission ce présent
la commission estime que cette
proposition fait doublon a eu le droit
existant en effet les paie lui comme
tous les documents d'urbanisme sont
soumis aux principes généraux du code de
l'urbanisme le préfet contrôler le
rebond respect au moment de
l'élaboration peut même demander à ce
que le pmu se modifier au besoin de au
besoin d'eux pour mieux respecter les
principes en cas de contentieux c'est le
juge qui vérifie videmment leur bonne
intégration parmi ces principes
justement figure aujourd'hui déjà la
diversité des fonctions urbaines et
rurales
la revitalisation des centres urbains et
ruraux l' équilibre entre les
populations urbaines et rurales
je pense que cet amendement est donc
pleinement amplement satisfait je suis
défavorable à vis du gouvernement
analyse je pense que c'est un signal
intéressant cet amendement il permet
vraiment d'afficher la volonté du
législateur de tenir compte des
équilibres à respecter entre les
territoires pour leur développement à
l'échelle stratégie du ps y est
d'inciter ainsi à une mutualisation des
objectifs de consommation des espaces
qui permet de ne pas pénaliser les
communes rurales dans la répartition de
ces objectifs et tenir compte de leurs
besoins
il va donc il me semble dans le sens
d'un des bleus
man équilibré du territoire et c'est
donc un avis très favorable merci je me
vois le 2088 avec un avis défavorable de
la commission favorable du gouvernement
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté 294 monsieur guay merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
est cher collègue la densification du
tissu urbain et le premier levier à
actionner afin de limiter
l'artificialisation des sols
à ce titre la sous utilisation des sols
dans ces zones et l'existence de dents
creuses doivent être combattus en détail
et le potentiel constructible établi par
les plus utilisés en plein cet
amendement contribuer veut contribuer
ainsi à lutter contre le mitage et
l'urbanisation du petit pavillon
périgordins si gourmand en terres
agricoles forestières naturel joueurs
merci merci avis la commission
ce président cet amendement prévoit de
donner au règlement de paix lui la
possibilité de forcer tous les
propriétaires dès qu'il souhaite
construire sur leurs terrains exploités
la totalité des droits à construire ce
que cela signifie concrètement qu'il
serait contraint de bâtir le moindre
centimètre carré autorisé par les règles
d'urbanisme d'exploiter au maximum la
hauteur autorisée etc
j'imagine que c'est une différence
philosophique mais la commission ne
souhaite parcourir de telles mesures qui
paraissent extrêmement intrusive équipe
usée contestable du point de vue du
droit de propriété
il nous semble que la densification doit
se faire via des méthodes douces et
qualitative et garantir l'acceptabilité
l'adhésion des habitants en outre cette
mesure est contre productive si le maire
est tenu de refuser tous les projets qui
ne maximisent pas la construction plus
personne ne souhaitera proposer des
projets et donc ces parcelles resteront
des friches enfin à l'heure où nous
parlons de nature en ville d'îlots de
chaleur du de qualité du cadre de vie de
végétalisation souhaitons nous renforcer
le français a bétonné au maximum des
possibilités à dire au revoir aux
jardins et aux patios l'avis est
défavorable
merci je mets aux voileux 194 à part de
remada
alors sur ce 194 effectivement je crois
que cette méthode elle ne permet pas de
concilier l'objectif de densification et
la préservation de la qualité urbaine
avec une mesure qui impliquerait de
construire sur l'emprise au sol maximale
de la zone et ce quelle que soit la
taille du terrain elle serait donc
inapplicable pour certaines tailles de
parcelles et puis elle ne permettrait
pas de préserver des espèces de pleine
terre et je crois que cette
densification qui doit résulter d'un
équilibre entre l'ambition des documents
d'urbanisme et un dialogue entre les
maîtres d'ouvragé l'autorité compétente
et bien d'autres doit être bien acceptée
et inséré c'est donc un avis défavorable
très bien je mets au voit donc cette
fois ci le 194 avec deux avis
défavorables quai pour quiconque il est
rejeté le 1143 vous en prie merci
monsieur le président cet amendement
consiste à mentionner expressément les
objectifs de la loi de 95 en ce qui
concerne les zones de revitalisation
rurale dans les éléments à prendre en
compte dans le cadre de la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols
il y à un quart de siècle le législateur
a formellement consacré des objectifs
sans que jusqu'à présent en tirer
réellement les conséquences je pense
notamment au troisième objectif qui est
je cite d'améliorer la qualité de
l'habitat et l'offre de logements
notamment locatif l'objectif de
régulation de l'artificialisation des
sols ne doit pas mettre les territoires
ruraux au second plan de notre politique
d'urbanisation l'interprétation actuelle
des lohas rend quasi impossible toute
construction en milieu l'oral en milieu
rural pardon nous l'avons tous entendue
dans nos intercommunalités lors de
l'élaboration de paix lui
alors où nos concitoyens souhaitent
légitimement s'installent à la campagne
les territoires ruraux ne sont pas
malheureusement en capacité d accueillir
merci à vis de la commission le
rapporteur sur le président de
partageons tous intentions de cet
amendement
c'est pourquoi en commission de savon
précisé étoffer les critères de
territorialisation nous avons également
consacré déjà le développement rural
parmi les objectifs du code d'urbanisme
nous avons réécrit les dispositions de
l'article 49 ans que celle ci fasse
explicitement mention des ederer et des
communes en perte et démographique
les autres objectifs auxquels cet
amendement fait référence c'est à
l'habitat l'accès aux services et
l'activité économique sont également
explicitement inscrits aux articles 48
et 49
cet amendement est donc amplement
satisfait la condition on demande le
retrait à défaut laissera enfin
défavorable ah oui du gouvernement des
ministres
oui sachant que ce décret a prévu pour
la territorialisation des objectifs de
réduction de l'artificialisation au
niveau régional a été supprimée par la
commission du sénat votre proposition
qui visait à le compléter n'ad'abord
plus de fondement juridique mais plus
précisément avec l'amendement 20,87 qui
a été adoptée qui vise la prise en
compte de la problématique des communes
rurales dans les scot et l'épée élus
nous avons effectivement une prise en
compte des enjeux spécifiques de ces
communes dans la déclinaison des
objectifs de réduction de
l'artificialisation c'est donc une
demande de retrait sinon l'avis
défavorable
très bien on dirait voiture le 8 197
n'est pas défendu le 898 quasiment même
moteur n'est pas défendu le 1815 de la
commission sur le rapporteur
le président de l'amendement de la
commission décision juridique clarifie
l'articulation entre consommation
d'espacé artificialisation merci à villa
du gouvernement le ministre un
amendement rédactionnelle de 1815
favorable sans merci je mets aux voix
l'amendement de la commission
rédactionnelle qui et pour qui compte
il est adopté quatre amendements
discussion commune le 1193 madame paoli
gaza oui monsieur le président il s'agit
par cet amendement d'exclure de la
définition de la notion
d'artificialisation l'extension d'une
construction d'un aménagement d'une
installation ou une activité existante
avant la promulgation de la loi
l'objectif étant de ne pas obérer
l'extension des projets industriels en
courant vise ou envisagées et de les
sécuriser et le 1323 monsieur dream
c'est d'ailleurs la ministre cet
amendement et au mot près le même donc
il est défendu d 2192 pas défendu 1322
monsieur chaize ou ceux de l'icta oui
monsieur le président en fait cet
amendement vise à exclure
bénéficiant de la nation d'artifice à
sion l'extension d'une construction dans
l'aménagement d'une installation une
activité existante avant la promulgation
de la présente loi lorsque cette
extension intervient au sein d'une
réserve foncière constitué avant cette
même date
merci avis de la commission sur les
trois amendements
le président les amendements 1193 me 323
presque identiques qui vise donc à ne
pas comptabiliser l'artificialisation
résultant des extensions de bâtiments
existants il me semble que si nous
voulons avoir une image fidèle de
l'artificialisation les extensions
doivent être comptabilisés prenons des
extensions de grands bâtiments
économiques ou des extensions même
limité dans les zones naturelles et
agricoles je ne pense pas qu'il faut
ignorer ces impacts
par ailleurs je signale que toutes les
extensions qui se réaliseront sur des
sols déjà artificialisées des cours
bitume et des sols déjà modifié par
l'homme et autres n'auront aucun impact
sur le chiffre total de
l'artificialisation nouvelle je pense
que dans un certain nombre des cas visés
par les amendements ils sont en réalité
satisfait la commission est défavorable
à ces amendements et ensuite pour le 13
22 la commission est également
défavorable qui vise à exclure le début
des comptes l'artificialisation des
extensions au sein des réserves
foncières
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
effectivement je crois qu ajouter cette
nouvelle dérogation serait que nous nous
en comptabilisant les éventuelle
extension de construction installation
existante élargir affaiblirait à nouveau
le champ d'application de de la volonté
initiale de ce texte avec donc une
précision au 13 23 qui élargit encore ce
champ des dérogations et qui en
affaiblit la portée ce sont donc des
avis défavorables
très bien je le retire monsieur le
président que moi aussi il reste quoi
alors monsieur chaize
tout est retiré alors il me reste aucun
très bien bien sûr j'ai plus rien à
faire c'est très bien aller deux
amendements identiques le 1291 madame
d'helmand coraux pulis je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
cet amendement vise à clarifier la loi
tel qu amendé par le sénat sur
l'interprétation de la notion
l'extension effective des espaces
urbanisés pour que le droit commun les
extensions continuité des espaces
urbanisés ne soit pas calé sur la loi
littoral pour l'ensemble des communes et
intercommunalités qui n'y seraient pas
soumises
la jurisprudence est en effet très
particulières s'agissant du régime de
ces extensions et n'est pas transposable
en dehors des zones littorales
en effet selon l'exposé des motifs
l'amendement numéro 188 adopté en
commission viserait a seulement précisé
que les projets situés dans les secteurs
de taille et de capacité d'accueil
limitée ou dans les dents creuses des
communes soumises à la loi littoral
identifié vers des schémas de cohérence
territoriale et plans locaux d'urbanisme
comme secteurs déjà urbanisés ne seront
pas considérés comme de l'art petits
fichiers lisation par les documents
d'urbanisme
l'application cet amendement pourrait
toutefois ce n'est pas un actif y et
permettre une généralisation de la
jurisprudence très restrictive des
extensions à l'urbanisation en loi
littoral littoral merci le 1973 n'est
pas défendu à huy la commission ce
président c'est un amendement qui
apporterait une précision rédactionnelle
avec un avis favorable à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
il me semble qu'on va au delà du
rédactionnel avec effectivement un ajout
qui neutralise toute consommation des
espaces dans des secteurs qui méritent
particulièrement des préserve d'être
préservé les territoires relevant de la
loi littoral d'abord et puis les zones
agricoles avec des secteurs de taille de
capacités qui sont dits limité à dessin
et je crois que favoriser
l'artificialisation à proximité du
littoral comme l'extension du mitage en
zone agricole va vraiment à l'encontre
de l'objectif qui est recherché par
cette fois c'est donc ce sont donc des
avis défavorables
merci je mets aux voileux 1291 avec un
avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté je fasse à six amendements
identiques un sous-amendement le 1314
madame simple merci monsieur le
président la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols et le
développement des yeux nerfs sont deux
politiques fondamentales pour réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre or
certaines installations de production
d'énergie renouvelable n'ont qu'une
incidence marginale sur les fonctions
écologiques du sol par exemple dans le
cadre de panneaux photovoltaïques
reposant sur des piquets directement
plantées dans le sol naturel de plus
dans cet exemple l'installation
photovoltaïque est complètement
réversible à l'issue de leur
exploitation
le présent amendement vise donc à
permettre de ne pas comptabiliser les
installations d'énergies renouvelables
qui ont une incidence marginale sur les
fonctions écologiques des sols agricoles
ou naturelles les installations situées
sur des sols forestiers ne pourront pas
bénéficier de cette souplesse car de
telles installations engendre une
déforestation ce régime particulier qui
ne durera que durant la période
transitoire de 10
sont prévus par le fbi du grand troyes
de l'article 49 se justifie par
l'importance des énergies renouvelables
pour la transition écologique
à l'issue de cette période de 10 ans la
nomenclature des sols artificialisés
prévue par l'article 48 permettra de
traiter le cas des installations
d'énergies renouvelables je vous
remercie
merci identique le 1796 sodomie défendu
identique le 1950 proche du père s'il
est bien défendu et bien identique le
1960 madame jour d'art à part de
défendre défendu merci vous n'êtes pas
co signataires dont je préférais que ce
soit madame jourdain qui me le dise
défendu merci de 1988
pas soutenu et le 1992
madame jacques et défendu veut défendre
goodey le sous-amendement 2292 monsieur
marche
oui monsieur le président un
sous-amendement qui a pour objet
d'indiquer le fait qu'une installation
photovoltaïque implantée sur un espace
naturel ou agricole doit pas être
incompatible avec l'exercice d'une
activité agricole ou pastorale sur ce
même terrain et ce quel que soit le
document d'urbanisme par lequel est
soumise la commune
en outre ce présence notamment de
sous-amendements introduire renvoie à un
décret en conseil d'état afin de
faciliter la mise en oeuvre pratique des
dispositions d'un moment 1314 merci à
vis de la commission le président je
remercie mes collègues d'avoir mis en
avant cette proposition pour atteindre
les objectifs que nous fixer la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
il faut que la france accélère son
effort de déploiement des installations
solaires de plus en plus d'initiatives
voit le jour dans les territoires pour
concilier solaire et activités par
exemple en matière d'agro volta isme qui
permet d'associer production d'énergie
et activités agricoles la commission est
donc favorable à l'intention collective
exprimée par ses six amendements qui
permettra de ne pas freiner l'effort en
faveur de l'énergie solaire l'amendement
notre collègue daniel grémillet fait
l'objet d'un sous-amendement 22 92 qui
propose de préciser que
l'artificialisation ne sera décompté que
si l'installation solaire n'est pas
incompatible avec l'activité agricole ou
pastorales la commission n'a pas pu se
prononcer sur ce sous amendement déposé
tardivement mais à titre personnel j'y
suis favorable
c'est bien l'esprit de ce projet de loi
que de concilier les besoins de
préserver notamment des surfaces
agricoles utiles paraît donc important
de préciser que l'activité agricole ne
doit pas être rendue impossible par
l'installation je crois que des
expérimentations sont menées par le
ministère de l'agriculture sur l'agro
volta isme les premiers retours
d'expérience permettront de préciser le
cadre de la disposition par décret et
donc je récapitule par avis favorable à
vis du gouvernement madame la ministre
sur ces amendements à la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols et le
développement des panneaux
photovoltaïques au sol
vous l'avez dit ce sont deux politiques
en faveur de la transition énergétique
qu'il convient absolument 2
d'articuler avec pour les dix premières
années un dispositif fondé sur la
consommation des espaces naturels
agricoles et forestiers qui a été
privilégiée en raison de sa meilleure
appropriation par les territoires
actuellement les panneaux
photovoltaïques qui s'en souvient permis
de construire seront par défaut
comptabilisés comme de la consommation
des espaces alors même que selon les
modalités techniques de pose ils peuvent
ne pas affecter durablement les
conditions écologiques des sols
votre proposition qui consiste à ne pas
comptabiliser comme de la consommation
des espaces 9 les installations
d'énergie photovoltaïque réversible qui
n'affecterait pas durablement les
fonctions écologiques des sols apparaît
donc tout à fait pertinente et c'est
bien uniquement parce qu'il s'agit
d'anticiper cette définition en
favorisant les projets qui narre
petit-fils ya lise effectivement pas que
je consens à cette exception avec donc
le sous-amendement 22 92 qui lui se
propose de compléter par voie
réglementaire dans un souci de sécurité
juridique en renvoyer au décret le soin
de préciser ses modalités techniques des
pâtes des panneaux qui n'affecterait pas
durablement les sols ce sont donc des
avis favorable à ces amendements sous
réserve de l'adoption du sous-amendement
22,92 très bien alors je vais mettre on
voit d'abord l'amendement 22 92 avec
deux avis favorable qu'est pour et bien
et je mets aux voix l'ensemble des
amendements identiques avec deux avis
favorables qui est pour ils sont adoptés
ainsi que le sous-amendement maintenant
huit amendements discussion commune avec
d'abord le 1830 de la commission
monsieur leur porter tout d'abord
laissez-moi dire que notre commission
sous la houlette notre présidente a
longuement débattu de ces sujets ce
avons souhaité nous assurer que les
mesures proposées ne faisait que ne
faisait pas peser une charge trop lourde
sur les collectivités que les délais
fixés n'était pas irréaliste et enfin
que la mécanique en cascade fonctionner
la commission estime que si l'on veut
effectivement enclencher un effort
ambitieux en faveur de la réduction de
l'artificialisation net
alors il est nécessaire que les
documents d'urbanisme intègre
progressivement et de manière
différenciée ses nouveaux objectifs nous
semble que l' équilibre obtenu est le
bon en conséquence et la commission sera
défavorable aux amendements 2000 2001
2002 2003 2004 et 568
qui vise à supprimer les délais
d'intégration et à supprimer les
conditionnalités relatives au scot et
plu et l'amendement 797 qui entend
supprimer un alinéa pourtant utile qui
prévoit que l'évolution des pl us code
puisse être engagée lors de l'évaluation
de neuf et six ans rendez vous qui sont
qui sont déjà prévues par là par la loi
ne s'agit pas d'une dérogation est
introduite par la commission
contrairement à ce qu'indiquent les
auteurs j'y suis donc défavorable et
l'amendement dit 138 la commission de la
commission vise à clarifier au maximum
ces dispositions complexes relatives aux
documents d'urbanisme et à l'intégration
en cascade des objectifs la rédaction
issue de l'assemblée manque de la clarté
nécessaire certaines dispositions sont
contradictoires novembre donc offrir
nous devons d'offrir aux élus locaux
pardon une feuille de route claire à
laquelle ils puissent rapidement et
qu'on comprend des obligations qui
s'imposent à eux l'amendement clarifie
donc documents par document quelle est
la marche à suivre et les délais
applicables et géré par aussi un oubli
de coordination merci le 2 797 monsieur
salmon merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre les taxis de la
rédaction de l'assemblée prévoyait
qu'une délibération du conseil municipal
ou communautaire décide de prescrire la
révision ou modification du document
d'urbanisme
la commission a modifié cette rédaction
pour prévoir que le conseil délibère sur
l'opportunité d'engager la procédure
d'évolution nous proposons de supprimer
cette dérogation qui nous paraît par
trop imprécises et qui pourrait générer
une insécurité juridique
merci c'est le 2000 2001 2002 2003 2004
ne sont pas défendus le 568 monsieur
denis coderre défendu et avis de la
commission donc en dehors du vôtre
naturellement sur le rapporteur sur les
autres amendements défavorable surtout
j'avais compris donc madame la ministre
l'ensemble
autant je serai
défavorable mais comme tout autre
amendement qui aurait souhaité une
suppression de délais ou de ou de
sanction donc concernant le 797 j'ai par
contre un avis de sagesse sur
l'amendement 1830 puisque je crois que
cette nouvelle structuration elle est
bienvenue dans des dispositions
transitoires qui permettent aux
documents d'urbanisme d'intégrer
objectifs de réduction du rythme
d'artificialisation je crois que la
lisibilité du dispositif s'en trouve
renforcée même si cet amendement reprend
la rédaction des dispositions résultant
des travaux de la commission qui ont
porté à trois ans le délai octroyé aux
documents de planification pour intégrer
nos objectifs de réduction de
l'artificialisation il consolide ainsi
cet allongement auquel je ne suis pas
favorable mais en tout cas sur le sur le
dispositif et sur la lisibilité du
dispositif surtout j'aime j'aime et donc
année un avis de sagesse très bien eh
bien nous allons mettre aux voix tout de
suite le 1832 la commission avec un avis
de sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté et il fait tomber le reste
le 1816 de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
ce président c'est l'amendement
rédactionnelle tionnel à vis du
gouvernement à vis du gouvernement de la
ministre
je mets aux voileux 1816 de la
commission avec avis favorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui quand il
est adopté le 1997 n'est pas assise
monsieur de colle et là le 1997 monsieur
de cole défendu très bien avis de la
commission sur une 1997 ce président le
texte de loi permet déjà d'autoriser le
recours à la modification simplifiée qui
est la forme la plus simple d'évolution
se souhaite pas aller au delà car paraît
important de garantir une forme de
participation du public et des acteurs à
des ces décisions structurantes la vie
et donc défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre cette déclaration de projet
c'est une procédure qui s'applique à
certains projets d'aménagement et qui
permet de mettre en compatibilité
manière accélérée ces documents
d'urbanisme cette mise en compatibilité
d'un document elle constitue une
procédure dérogatoire qui se limite
strictement à rendre compatible
documents d'urbanisme avec un projet
déclare elle ne peut donc pas excédé le
champ du du projet et n'est donc pas la
procédure adéquate pour l'intégration au
sein des documents d'urbanisme des
objectifs qui sont légalement définit
donc un avis défavorable
eh bien il est maintenu et monsieur de
colle de 282 n'est pas défendu je mets
aux veaux à l'article 49 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est adopté après l'article 49 quatre
amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 701 monsieur
decool défendu le 58e
monsieur baci et défendu mieux défendu
je le sens aller et défendu le 245
monsieur decool défendu il nous reste le
292 monsieur kuipers
il est défendu je le sentais bien suis
aussi allé avis de la commission sur ces
quatre amendements défendus surprise
dans la loi des prévoit déjà des
modalités en plus de concertation et de
consultation du public les organisations
de la filière du bâtiment peuvent faire
valoir leur point de vue dans ce cadre
leur association systématique est formel
ne paraît pas pertinent c'est donc un
avis défavorable
et concernant les amendements 58 à 145
de 192 khz qui prévoit l'association
leur demande des professionnels de la
filière du bâtiment au scot pour les
mêmes raisons la commission est
défavorable à vis du gouvernement madame
la ministre
les organisations professionnelles et
leur rôle au sein du collège des
professionnels du conseil supérieur de
la construction et de l'efficacité et de
formuler un avis sur l'ensemble des
projets associés leurs représentants à
l'élaboration de documents de
planification ne paraît pas opportun
dans la mesure où les objectifs qui
seront fixées porte davantage sur la
programmation à la mixité sociale dans
l'habitat pour répondre aux besoins de
la population que sur véritablement la
qualité de la construction qui se
réfléchit au stade du projet par
ailleurs je crois que le fait d'ajouter
à la liste des personnes publiques
associées
ces associations professionnalisation
professionnel aurait pour effet
d'alourdir et d'allonger la procédure
ainsi que son coût sachant que les ppa
peuvent demander à être consulté tout au
long de la procédure et émettre un avis
qui est joint au dossier d'enquêté
publique
c'est ce sont donc des avis défavorables
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
ces amendements d'abord le 7 1 avec deux
avis défavorables quai pour qui et pour
personne dans
que contre alors voilà il est rejeté
ensuite trois identique le 58 245 292
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre
ils sont rejetés toujours après
l'article 49 1 195 monsieur guay merci
monsieur le président cet amendement
vise à ne pas soumettre aux
prescriptions de l'article l100 42 tirs
et 4 du code de l'urbanisme les communes
classées en zone de revitalisation
rurale où ils ont subi une perte
démographique continue durant les dix
dernières années joueurs merci merci oui
la commission se faisait dans les
auteurs de cet amendement soit dispensé
les communes rurales en perte
démographique la commission n'y est pas
favorable
c'est au gouvernement nous avons dit
7690 communes qui sont en zrr
actuellement sur un total de 34 mille
neuf cent quarante et une communes soit
plus de 50% et que la disposition
proposée pourrait avoir un impact
conséquent sur la consommation des
espaces puisque selon les statistiques
et données du serema de 2009 à 2019 ces
communes ont consommé malheureusement
30% des espaces naturels agricoles et
forestiers sur l'ensemble du territoire
vous comprendrez que j'ai un avis
défavorable merci je mets aux voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
et pour qui et pour monsieur guay aller
voilà qui est contre merci les rejeter
le 1877 n'est pas défendu
le 2174 du gouvernement madame la
ministre
2174 qui se propose donc de ratifier les
ordonnances prises en application des
articles 46 et 50 de la loi et
l'emportant notamment sur les scot ces
ordonnances elle réorganise la
hiérarchie des normes et l'articulation
des documents d'urbanisme elle modernise
lescott qui sont en vigueur depuis le
1er avril 2021
elles constitueront de nouveau corpus
juridique un d'évolution des documents
d'urbanisme et qui sera utilisée pour
faire évoluer les documents selon les
termes du présent projet de loi avec ce
rappel cette réforme qui permet
notamment aux auteurs de schéma de
cohérence territoriale et en l'absence
de scot de plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal de disposer d'une note
d'enjeux du préfet à leurs demandes qui
leur donne la maîtrise du calendrier et
des mises en comptabilisant
compatibilité et qui permet également de
réduire le nombre de documents
opposables aux scot c'est ratification
elle a donc une portée purement
technique elle permettra en particulier
que l'ensemble des dispositions prévues
à l'article 49 s'applique aux textes en
vigueur si vous voulez bien merci à vis
de la commission sera porteur ce
président comme le sénat l'a relevé dans
son bilan annuel l'application des lois
ces ordonnances apporte un certain
nombre d'évolutions bienvenus elles ont
notamment prévu des simplifications des
rapports entre documents d'urbanisme et
renforcer le rôle intégrateur des scot
rénover en profondeur ces documents il
faut donc saluer cet effort dont profite
toutefois pour m'adresser à madame la
ministre
à peine un an après la parution de
l'ordonnancé de rationalisation et de
modernisation de documents d'urbanisme
le projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vient opéré de nouveau
changement
ajout du contenu nouveau scot accroît la
portée des sera dette implique la
révision cascade ces centaines de
documents les dommages que les efforts
de simplification déstabilisation soit
souvent remise en cause par de nouvelles
couches législatives quelques mois après
au demeurant la vie la commission est
favorable
très bien je mets aux voileux 2174 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté après l'article 49-2
amendements identiques le 27 monsieur
decaux
si ce président cet amendement vise
voudrais le dire simplement que
lorsqu'un porteurs de projets sollicite
une autorisation d'urbanisme famille
construire par exemple eh bien il ne
devrait pas obtenir ce permis
si toutefois l'étude agricole et la
compensation agricoles collectives n'ont
pas été mises en oeuvre
[Musique]
merci amendements identiques 900 la
ministre mes chers collègues le mans
demain viennent d'être très bien
défendue par notre collègue de colle de
je le considère défendu très bien et
avis de la commission là dessus ce
président-là compensation collective
agricole prévoit je rappelle que les
porteurs de projets qui consomment des
terres à vocation agricole doivent
compenser cette destruction d'activités
agricoles par des aides financières ou
concrète à la filière agricole locale
dans le droit actuel le porteur du
projet doit réaliser des études
préalables qui établit l'impact du
projet et les mesures de compensation à
mettre en oeuvre la cdp nafkha
aujourd'hui un avis motivé sur cette
étude avant que le préfet ne la valide
les amendements prévoient de rendre cet
avis conforme et qui sont obligatoires
avant toute autorisation d'urbanisme
en outre il souhaite que les porteurs de
projets qui ne respectaient pas leurs
obligations de compensation puissent
être poursuivis en justice
ces propositions semblent de nature à
assurer le respect des obligations
légales de composition à l'école et la
commission qui est donc favorable mais
du gouvernement madame la ministre
moi il me semble même si effectivement
nous partageons bien évidemment cet
objectif de renforcer les procédures
pour prendre en compte et mieux prendre
en compte pour dé prendre des projets
d'ampleur les conséquences négatives de
l'économie agricole je crois que la
procédure d'étude préalable agricole et
l'autorisation d'urbanisme sont deux
démarches tout à fait distincte avec un
avis de la commission départementale de
protection des espaces naturels
agricoles et forestiers qui ne porte pas
sur le bien-fondé du projet mais sur le
contenu et la qualité de l'étude
préalable agricole au regard de
l'existence d'effets
gatif je crois que conditionné
l'autorisation d'urbanisme à l'avis
conforme de cette commission sur cette
étude serait une mesure sans doute
disproportionnés
et puis sans avoir recours au mécanisme
de compensation collective des
dispositifs existent pour protéger les
fonctionnalités agricole vous le savez
les zones agricoles protéger les apps ou
les périmètres de protection des espaces
agricoles et naturels périurbains et
donc il me semble que ces outils
répondent à l'objectif que vous
recherchez c'est en pin demande de
retrait sinon avis défavorable très bien
je vais au voit donc les deux
amendements identiques 27 et 950 et avec
un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
ils sont adoptés et je passe à l'article
49 bis à qui avait été supprimé mais le
922 monsieur seulement pour
éventuellement le rétablir tout à fait
monsieur le président merci madame la
ministre
créé initialement pour contribuer à la
préservation du foncier non bâti dans le
cadre de la planification urbaine les
commission départementale des espaces
naturels agricoles et forestiers ont vu
leur vocation première restreinte lors
de la loi du 13 octobre 2014 pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et de la
forêt ce qui ne leur permet plus d'être
consultés même de manière facultative
sur les plus dès lors que les communes
concernées sont situées dans un
périmètre de schéma de cohérence
territoriale à prouver or au regard de
la déclinaison d'objectifs d'absence de
tout artificialisation net des sols dans
l'ensemble des documents de
planification en visée envisagée par ce
projet de loi il paraît pertinent que
les cdpe hénaff instance de dialogue
utile et impartiale puisse jouer
pleinement leur rôle et être consulté si
elle le souhaite sur tous les plans
locaux d'urbanisme
cette commission composée d'acteurs
directement concerné par le plus
profession agricole et forestière
chambre d'agriculture propriétaires
fonciers aux associations de protection
de l'environnement chasseurs pêcheurs
notaires etc
elle peut donc constituer un outil
efficace de concertation entre tous les
acteurs des territoires dans la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols le
présent amendement vise ainsi à
restaurer cette faculté d'auto saisine
qui existait dans les dispositions du
code rural antérieure à 2014
je vous remercie il y à vis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
c'est le président contrairement à ce
qu'avancent les auteurs de l'amendement
la cdp n'a jamais eu d'autosaisine sur
ces documents même avant 2014
au contraire la loi d'avenir pour
l'agriculture a donné cette faculté sur
les documents non convient dans un scot
et la précision relative à la couverture
par un scot a été apportée par le sénat
pour limiter les doublons procéduraux
lors de l'élaboration des documents
d'urbanisme
au vu du chant déjà large de la saisine
actuel de la cdp n'a fait la commission
a estimé qu'ils n'étaient pas pertinents
d'alourdir encore les obligations
procédurales applicables au pmu elle est
donc logiquement défavorable
merci à vis du gouvernement la ministre
j'aurai un avis plus nuancé
parce que d'abord dans le droit actuel
les pays dont le territoire est couvert
par un scot ne sont pas soumis à l'avis
de la cdp neufs qui ne peut s'autosaisir
de l'examen d'un p lus que si le scot et
est antérieure à 2014 et la loi allures
de 2014 en effet clarifier cette
hiérarchie des normes
néanmoins c'est au niveau du perray luxe
apprécient finement les différentes
applications relatives à la consommation
de death passe et il existe
effectivement une différence d'échelle
de précision et d'opposabilité entre un
scot qui portent sur un large territoire
un pays à l'ue qui s'attache à l'échelle
cadastrales et c'est à cette échelle que
la commission peut s'assurer que la
collectivité a mobilisé l'ensemble des
solutions qui visait à minimiser la
consommation et à maintenir la
fonctionnalité des espaces donc cette
cette mesure est les cibles elles ne
visent pas à multiplier les cas d'examen
par la cdp 9
la saisine n'est pas obligatoire elle
peut avoir lieu dans un temps où
d'autres consultations obligatoires
interviennent tels que l'examen des
personnes publiques associées
et puis la vie n'est n'est pas conforme
donc dans la mesure où d'une part les
scot constitue déjà une garantie forte
et où d'autre part l'auto-saisine
présente certains atouts pour une
approche plus fine
je m'en remettrai à la sagesse des
sénateurs très bien je vais donc mettre
aux voix le 922 avec un avis défavorable
de la commission sagesse du gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté et je mets
zoo vous à ben non le quart 9 bis à
reste supprimés à l'article car 9 bis b
deux amendements discussion commune le
1536 monsieur dont sarrazy 2006 monsieur
le président madame la ministre
l'article 49 bis pose la question de la
renaturation de sa définition et de la
capacité des scot a piloté cette forme
de compensation de l'artificialisation
qu'est ce qu'on entend par le terme
renaturation la reconquête par la nature
des milieux dégradés délaissés ou
détruits par les activités humaines
sous quelle forme peut-elle être mise en
oeuvre en la laissant en laissant la
nature reprendre ses droits avec une
intervention extérieure et selon quelle
méthodologie
face à ces incertitudes sur les contours
de cette notion de renaturation certes
ambitieuse et vertueuse notre amendement
propose de s'en tenir à la notion de
transformation des sols artificialisés
en sol non artificialisés sans engrais
le terme de remettre à sion merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
donc il s'agit également d'un amendement
qui vise à préciser la rédaction de cet
article est de remplacer le terme de
renaturation qui n'a pas d'existence
scientifique par celui de restauration
en effet un sol qui a été artificialisés
tasser et stérilisés à cause intrants
par exemple a perdu et ses fonctions de
perméabilité de biodiversité de puits de
carbone et de possibilité de donner lieu
à de l'alimentation
donc ce qu on peut faire ça n'est pas si
on le laisse vous et à lui-même il
mettra des milliers d'années à se
reformer et de toute façon il ne
retrouvera pas son état antérieur
parce que ça n'est pas possible donc la
seule chose qu'on puisse faire c'est de
restaurer le sol en y portant des
amendements de la matière
des lombrics et à ce moment là on
l'appellera donc un sol restaurer mal
nommer les choses c'est ajouter au
malheur du monde disait albert camus et
comme nicolas boileau selon que notre
idée est plus ou moins obscures
l'expression la suie ou moins ned ou
plus pur journal très bien avec la
commission sur ces deux amendements du
rapporteur ce président concernant
l'amendement 1536 qui vise à supprimer
la notion de renaturation il est vrai
que cette notion n'était pas définies
par le présent projet de loi toutefois
l'amendement présenté par la commission
à l'article 48 à clarifier ce qu'est la
renaturation je vous le rappelle
rapidement la renaturation d'un sol ou
des artificialisation consiste en des
opérations de rétablissement ou
d'amélioration de la fonctionnalité d'un
sol ayant pour effet de transformer un
sols artificialisés en sol non
artificialisés cela correspond à
l'intention des auteurs ça c'est cette
incertitude étant désormais levées la
commission est défavorable à cet
amendement et l'amendement 740 qui vise
à supprimer la notion de renaturation
utilisés à cet article pour la remplacer
par la notion de restauration la
restauration n'est pas non plus définies
par le code de l'urbanisme et comme
évoqué la commission a introduit la 48
une définition de la renaturation même
avis défavorable à la ministre je
rejoins monsieur le rapporteur
j'ajouterai que ce terme de renaturation
qui est quand même très clos communément
utilisés en urbanisme en architecture et
en conservation de la nature
cette cette notion elle constitue une
composante essentielle de l'atteinte de
cet objectif than qui nécessite de
combiner la réduction de la
socialisation et la re naturalisation la
renaturation pardon des terres
artificialisés il est donc je crois
absolument essentiel de le conserver de
conserver c'est le fait de pouvoir
prévoir ces zones préférentielles de
renaturation à l'échelle du scot qui
seront déclinés après de manière plus
opérationnelle dans les pays à lui dans
un lien de compatibilité je suis donc
défavorable aux 15 36 de même qu'aux 740
puisque ce terme de renaturation il
il permet effectivement à des milieux
ayant subi des perturbations anthropique
d'évoluer vers un état proche de son
état naturel initial mais ces évolutions
elles peuvent être spontanée ou conduite
par l'homme dans un ensemble
d'opérations sont donc deux avis
défavorables
merci je mets aux voies d'abord le 1536
deux avis défavorables qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté le 740 deux avis
défavorables qui pour et contre
il est rejeté je me revois l'article 49
bis bis quai pour qui est contre il est
adopté
après l'article 9 bis b 1 1554 que sur
odon sarrazy oui monsieur le président
un ministre l' agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires structures
déconcentrées désormais le principal
opérateur au service de l'aménagement du
territoire sa feuille de route présentée
il ya tout juste un an oriente ses
actions sur trois thématiques
prioritaires dont celle des ruralités et
l'accompagnement des grandes transitions
dans les territoires ruraux
l'objectif du zen en 2050 et de
l'aménagement durable du territoire
implique un ajustement des missions
dance était cette agence pourra en effet
utilement accompagner soutenir les
communes rurales dans cette évolution
importante et structurante et mobiliser
les moyens nécessaires en matière
d'ingénierie
merci avis la commission ce présent
l'accompagnement des collectivités
effectivement sera la clé notamment en
matière d'ingénierie paraît donc très
pertinent de consacrer parmi les
missions dnct la lutte contre
l'artificialisation ce sera un avis
favorable à vis du gouvernement madame
la ministre
l'agencé nationale de cohésion des
territoires à la formation de conseiller
de soutenir les collectivités et leurs
groupements dans la définition et la
mise en oeuvre de leurs projets et
notamment en matière de transition
écologique et de développement
économiques
par ailleurs ces contrats d'objectifs et
de performance de l' agence en cours
d'élaboration
il prévoit que celle ci accompagne les
territoires dans leur stratégie de
transition et de résilience en francs
que cette réalisation de cet objectif
elle sera évaluée
au travers du suivi d'un indicateur qui
est dédié qui évalue le nombre de
projets territoriaux accompagné par la
société et qui prend en compte des
transition écologique énergétique
d'émissions de l' agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires tels quels sont
donc définie par la loi qui permettent
déjà d'accompagner les collectivités
territoriales et leurs copains dans cet
objectif de zéro artificialisation net
en 2050 et d'un aménagement durable du
territoire
il ne me semble donc pas souhaitable de
commencer à les listes et au risque de
ne pas être exhaustif des trains
complets c'est donc un avis cinq
demandes de retrait sinon avis
défavorable très bien je mets aux
voileux 1554 avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour favorable pardon favorable
de la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté je mets au voit maintenant
l'article 49 bis etc et pour qui est
contre il est adopté à l'article 49 bis
d un amendement 1817 monsieur le
rapporteur
c'est un amendement mais surprise en cas
pour des précisions rédactionnelle à vis
du gouvernement favorable
je mets aux voileux 1817 avec un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est adopté je mets aux voix l'article
49 bis des quais pour qui compte
il est adopté à l'article 49 bis eu un
amendement 291 monsieur kuipers
oui monsieur président un amendement de
lesieu favreau qui
cet article modifie donc l'article 151
22 du code de l'urbanisme et imposant le
règlement dp du des collectivités
comprise dans une zone tendue de la
définition d'une part minimale de
surface de pleine terre ou éco
aménageable il est donc proposé par cet
amendement la suppression de cet article
sachant que celui-ci n'empêchera pas les
collectivités qui le souhaitent et en
fonction de leur besoin de définir une
part minimale de surfaces non un père
mais alizé non imperméabilisées ou éco
aménageable six avis de la commission
ce président ce coefficient est
aujourd'hui déjà les facultés pour les
pl us ayant un outil de nombreuses
communes ne s'en saisisse effectivement
y compris en zone tendue je ne souhaite
pas le supprimer car il me semble qu'il
permet d'assurer que la densification
des villes ne passe pas uniquement par
le béton mais aussi qu'elle laisse la
place de petits jardins parcs patio
l'obligation de l'instaurer en zone
tendue peut paraître certes
disproportionnée mais je rappelle
toutefois que les communes pourront
fixer un taux bas si elle le souhaite et
facilement atteignable en commission
nous sommes prononcés pour une
amélioration dispositif plutôt que ces
suppressions
nous avons notamment prévu que ce
coefficient ne s'applique pas aux
opérations de mener sur des bâtiments
existants afin de répondre aux
inquiétudes qui ont été exprimées
notamment par les organismes de logement
social savons aussi prévu que les
surfaces végétalisée puisse être
mutualisés à l'échelle d'un projet comme
en commission mon avis est donc
défavorable
il est retiré madame la ministre donc on
va en rester là merci le 2089 monsieur
marchand
mais monsieur le président l'article 49b
ce visa imposée dans le pl une part
minimale de surface en pleine terre
végétalisée dans les espaces les plus
denses de france à savoir les zones
d'urbanisation continue de plus de 50000
habitants et les communes de plus de
15000 habitants en forte croissance
démographique
aussi afin d'adapter les exigences
attendues à la diversité des territoires
des communes cet amendement pour objet
de préciser que les part minimale de
surfaces non imperméabilisées ou éco
aménageable ils soient définies par
secteur avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur se précise monsieur le
président cette précision peut paraît
apporter une dose de souplesse al
obligation introduite à l'assemblée
nationale car les communes pourront
ainsi différenciée selon les enjeux
propres à chaque sexe
je suis donc favorable oui du
gouvernement madame la ministre je
plussoie il me semble effectivement
nécessaire de préciser que cette
obligation doit être ciblée sur ces
secteurs qui seront à définir leur
l'élaboration du pl us sachant qu'elle
ne sera pas applicable partout
évidemment c'est un avis fabre je mets
aux voileux 2089 avec deux avis
favorable qu'est pour qui et pour deux
avis favorables
je sais ce que je peux voilà qui compte
voilà il est adopté le 4 149 n'est pas
défendu je mets aux voileux car 9 bis ce
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté l'article 49 bis f
ah oui on en arrive là 1818 de la
commission le président cet amendement
vise à modifier l'imputation du permis
de végétaliser inséré à l'initiative de
deux commissions il est plus pertinent
de l'insérer dans le code général de la
propriété des personnes publiques car il
permet d'y déroger que dans le code de
l'urbanisme et à vis du gouvernement
je partage ce souhait de clarifier le
régime juridique de ces démarches de
végétalisation de l'espace public par
les habitants qui est initié par
certaines communes avec un cadre
législatif qui relève des règles
d'utilisation du domaine public et plus
spécifiquement des autorisations
d'occupation temporaire qui a bien
vocation à s'ingérer dans le code
général de la propriété des personnes
publiques et non dans le code de
l'urbanisme c'est donc un avis favorable
si je mets aux voileux 1818 de la
commission avec l'avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté je mets aux voix l'article
49 bis f à quai pour les contres il est
adopté je mets au voile article car 9
bis f qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté à l'article car 9 bis j'ai
un amendement 924 monsieur seulement on
si monsieur le président madame la
ministre cet amendement propose que
l'organe compétent en matière de
documents d'urbanisme des pâtes à minima
tous les trois ans au lieu de six ans
sur l'adéquation de la carte communale
en vigueur avec
rectif de la politique locale en matière
d'urbanisme et d'aménagement prévoir un
échange sur ce sujet majeur à mi mandat
plutôt qu'une fois tous les six ans nous
paraît davantage pertinent
merci avis du rapporteur ce président je
rappelle tout d'abord que cette
évaluation a été créée à l'initiative du
sénat en commission aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des documents d'urbanisme
sont sous sont soumis à évaluation
périlleux périodiques sauf la carte
communale
c'est donc apparu pertinent de les
inscrire aussi dans cette logique de
bilan
cette obligation est donc nouvelle et
touche qui fusaient à des petites
communes rurales majoritairement dans
ces communes n'est pas forcément
pertinent de modifier la carte tout des
années car on y construit - la
commission n'a donc pas souhaité que
l'évaluation soit que trop
contraignantes périodicité de trois ans
contre eux rien aujourd'hui apparaît
disproportionnée d'autant que la durée
prévue pour les scot est perdu et de 6
ans également la commission et donc
défavorable à vis du gouvernement mais
la ministre michelle jeu trek rien
n'empêche à la collectivité de débattre
de l'adéquation de cette carte communale
avec la politique d'urbanisme et
d'aménagement c'est donc également un
avis défavorable
je mets le 924 avec deux avis
défavorables aux voix qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté 1819 de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur le président
l'amendement de la commission vise à
mieux inscrire les cartes communales
dans une logique de bilan
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui pour
les pme et les scot lors de l'examen en
commission nous avons créé cet article
qui prévoit d'organiser tous les six ans
sein du conseil municipal un débat qui
porte sur l'adéquation entre les
orientations de la politique d'urbanisme
de la commune et sa carte communale nous
faisons tous le constat que de carte
communale d'attendre parfois d'il ya
plus de vingt ans où l'on ne se pose
plus la question de savoir si le
document est cohérent avec des enjeux
actuels de la vie communale je rappelle
qu'une telle évaluation existe déjà pour
les pme et les scot dans un format plus
poussée plus détaillée et pour faire
suite aux échanges que nous avons eus en
commission un amendement propose de
faire un pas supplémentaire dans cette
logique et de prévoir que comme pour les
pme et les scot le conseil municipal
délibère sur l'opportunité ou non de
réviser la carte
la révision n'est bien sûr qu'une
faculté la commune restant souveraine
merci à vis du gouvernement
je crois conduire ainsi communes
couvertes par une carte communale a tiré
les conclusions du débat périodiques
qu'elles doivent tenir sur leur
politique d'urbanisme par un vote
nous sommes en être une idée qui
concourent utilement notre objectif dans
ce projet de loi et notamment ceux de
lutte contre l'artificialisation ce donc
un avis favorable
merci je mets aux voileux 1819 de la
commission avec un avis favorable du
gouvernement qui et pour qui est content
il est adopté je mets ouvre à l'article
9 bis gic et pour qui est contre il est
adopté à l'article car 9 bis deux
amendements identiques le 1776
il n'est pas soutenu le 1980 monsieur de
colle il est défendu
il est défendu avis la commission alors
que le cet amendement porte se porte
actuellement sur le logement
d'amendements souhaité l'étendre aux
locaux à usage et économique
à ce stade la commission estime qu'il
n'est pas opportun de modifier le champ
de l'inventaire prévu les observatoire
de l'habitat et du foncier sont surtout
situées en zones tendues où la question
la plus pressante et celle de la pénurie
de logements
bien sûr il n'est pas inutile d'avoir
des données plus large mais ne
souhaitons pas rendre le volet locaux
économique obligatoire alors que les
observatoires existence se met à peine
en place avec des moyens limités et que
le présent article prévoit déjà d'en
étendre à porter je pense prématuré
d'élargir leur mission à l'implantation
d'activités économiques sont en revanche
tout à fait possible sur une base
volontaire
la vie et donc défavorable à vis du
gouvernement met la min et il est
maintenu ses écoles
il est odieux je mets au voile article
49 bis quai pour qui est contre il est
adopté
après l'article 9 bis 540 qui n'est pas
soutenue jeu mais non le 49e ri
supprimés
car neuf côté est supprimé l article car
9 points qui est supprimée mais deux
établissements deux amendements de
rétablissement le 1539 monsieur montaugé
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues cet événement propose de
rétablir la possibilité de conclure des
conventions de sobriété foncière cet
outil nous sommes le particulièrement
utile pour permettre d'accompagner les
collectivités qui le souhaitent dans la
tête de l'objectif du zéro
artificialisation net
cette convention offre des perspectives
intéressantes pour répondre aux enjeux
par exemple de la nature en ville ou
encore des continuités écologiques
la version qui les proposait de rétablir
et complétée de la réalisation conjointe
d'un état des lieux de la consommation
intérieure d'espacé c'était un des vieux
est en effet le point d'entrée à partir
duquel pourrait être défini
objectivement le volume
d'artificialisation possible dans le
cadre du projet global de territoire
envisager cette donnée contractuels
fondamentale permettra de disposer d'une
base commune est opérationnel pour
assurer le pilotage et le suivi de la
réalisation des objectifs fixés sur le
territoire couvert par la convention
avec la commission sur le reporter le
président notre mission et la commission
des lois on souhaitait supprimer cet
article je rappelle brièvement pourquoi
il est vrai que la proposition de ces
conventions est venue de certaines
organise de certaines organisations
d'élus locaux
cependant il faut comprendre la logique
initiale idée était de remplacer la
proche coercitives descendante du projet
de loi
il ya les objectifs dans l'estrade est
scott p lus par une contractualisation
entre collectivités et l'état
cependant à l'assemblée le gouvernement
a refusé que les conventions puisse
servir de cadre pour assouplir assouplir
les objectifs contraignants les modules
et l'échangé et notamment dans les
calendriers on se retrouve donc avec une
convention vidé de son intérêt en tant
qu'alternative ensuite votre commission
a estimé que ces conventions soulève
davantage d'interrogations que
l'enthousiasmé d'abord une assemblée que
la multiplication de ces contrats
conventions entre l'état et les
collectivités entraîne un véritable
problème de lisibilité pour les
politiques publiques et les crt eux
viennent à peine d'être déployés pour
rassembler les différents contrats
existants qu'on entend recréer déjà
d'autres les contrats existants déjà des
volets de sobriété foncière
territoire d'industrie par exemple
revitalisation des territoires c'était
eux et d'autres aussi je m'interroge par
ailleurs si cela ne conduira pas à
l'avenir à réserver certaines des aides
publiques ou dérogation aux seules
collectivités signataires on voit
qu'avec les eaux vertes et où les goûts
par exemple on se dirige vers un droit à
deux vitesses les périmètres de contrat
ont de plus en plus des aides et des
dérogations les autres non or aucune
convention ne peut être signée sans
l'état par définition sera il sera donc
possible pour l'état de choisir quelle
collectivité sera bénéficiaire et au
prix de quelques concessions
on peut y voir un risque et d'inégalités
territoriales dernier point il est
parfaitement possible dans le droit
existant de signer les avenants au
sérieux par exemple pour des volets de
sobriété foncière l'outil existe donc
déjà et pour toutes ces raisons la
commission est défavorable à vis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
ces amendements il complète la loi qui
engage dans une même dynamique et pour
une période commune l'ensemble des
échanges collectivités vers cet objectif
zéro artificialisation annette
d'ailleurs si les conventions de
sobriété foncières sont une possibilité
d'articuler les outils existants et ceux
mis en place par la présente loi elles
n'ont pas vocation à se substituer ou à
s'imposer aux documents de planification
et d'urbanisme ni même d'y déroger
et en ce sens je crois que la notion de
cadre de référence que vous introduisez
me semble
cependant elle est allée un peu loin
mais nous avons en tout cas dans un tel
contrat qui doit s'inscrire dans le
cadre des échéances fixées et des
objectifs et règles prévues par les
documents locaux nous avons bien
l'esprit que nous souhaitons donner à ce
nouvel outil facultatif
avec donc l'amendement 15 39 qui propose
néanmoins d'y ajouter un inventaire des
sols artificialisés au cours des dix
dernières années et qu'un décret en
précise les modalités avec une
convention qui peut comprendre toutes
les données en permettant la mise en
oeuvre et le suivi notamment de celles
qui sont utiles aux collectivités
compétentes et il ne me semble ici pas
opportun qu'un tel inventaire soit prévu
systématiquement pour chaque convention
et si précisément encadrée par la loi
je vous proposais je vous proposerai
donc le retrait au profit de
l'amendement
20 44 qui qui exclut cette disposition
[Musique]
eh bien monsieur marchand vous avez
d'ores et déjà un avis favorable du
gouvernement avant même de l'avoir
exposé vous considérez donc sur le coup
il défendu et vous avez un avis négatif
de la commission qui ne l'avait pas non
plus entendu mais qui est négatif
allez donc je me suis montaugé vous
maintenez vous maintenant on commence
par le 1539 de kelt est présentée par
monsieur montaugé avec donc deux avis
négatifs qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté et le 2044
qui alors lui un avis négatif de la
commission mais positif du gouvernement
qui est pur il est rejeté
article 49 qu'un qui est supprimé à
l'article 50 un amendement 130
oui je vous en prie monsieur canivez
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre cheikh collègues
il s'agit d'un amendement qui vise à
supprimer cet article car nous
considérons que d'imposer aux
collectivités communes ou pci des
charges supplémentaires de rapports sur
périodiques sur l'artificier
l'artificialisation des sols revient à
leur imposer donc une charge trop lourde
d'autant plus que cela est déjà prévu
dans le cadre des schémas régionaux dans
le cadre des schémas de cohérence
territoriale donc il n'ya pas lieu qu'il
y ait des doublons commission le
président notre commission a
significativement assoupi cette
obligation en réduisant la durée
initialement fixé un an à trois ans elle
a aussi permis est ce que l'évaluation
des pieds lui qui devra se tenir tous
les six ans puisse tenir lieu de ce
rapport et débat dans la rédaction
actuelle cet article implique donc un
rendez vous supplémentaire tous les six
ans en outre dans un esprit d'ambition
en vue de la réduction de ratifier les
sons nouvelle il nous a paru important
d'accroître l'information des élus sous
cette question mais aussi la
transparence vis-à-vis des habitants
puisque ce rapport sera rendu public le
gouvernement tandis indiqué que les
indiens les indicateurs précisément
fixée par un décret seront simples et
peu nombreux afin que la charge pour les
communes et e et opci soient minimales
madame la ministre j'aimerais vous
reposer la question devant cet hémicycle
vous engagez vous à ce que l'état
fournisse le soutien nécessaire à
l'établissement de ce rapport et à ce
que son format n'entraîne pas une charge
administrative disproportionné avec ses
réserves
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
à vis du gouvernement madame la ministre
c'est un c'est un avis défavorable qui
ne vous surprendra pas je crois que
l'élaboration et le contenu de ce
rapport qui me semble essentiel il se
veut résolument simple et concis et
précis avec seulement quelques
indicateurs calculé à partir de données
dont dispose facilement les communes ou
intercommunalités et je vous redis que
l'observatoire du ceram à sera présent
et ses données mises à disposition des
communes pour ce faire avec donc des
données sur les permis de construire le
portail national de l'artificialisation
sur les fichiers foncier et ocs vieux
qui seront précisées également un décret
en conseil d'état avec la production de
ce rapport qui ne souhaitent pas
s'imposer évidemment comme une charge
supplémentaire
et puis je crois que à travers
l'élaboration de ces rapports on
sensibilise en implique des élus
communaux et intercommunaux dans la
lutte contre l'artificialisation des
sols qui apparaît d'autant plus
essentiel qu'il dispose un des leviers
pour la limiter avec la délivrance des
permis de construire les décisions
d'ouverture à l'urbanisation la
planification locale où les politiques
de préservation de certains espaces pour
toutes ces raisons donc j'ai aimé un
avis défavorable
très bien donc j'ai le sens 30 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est rejeté 296 adam cohen oui
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les politiques
d'urbanisme se trouve progressivement
transférés à l'échelon intercommunal
pour autant nous considérons que la
compétence octroyé à l'intercommunalité
ne puisse pas celle des communes plus
ouverte à l'image leur importance pour
nos concitoyennes et nos concitoyens et
de la boussole qu'elle constitue nous
estimons donc qu'il est nécessaire de
prévoir la diffusion la plus vaste et la
plus accessible du savoir y compris
étant donnée leur haut niveau de
technicité et le nombre important de
réglementation transversale pouvant
entrer en jeu
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons que
l'ensemble des élus municipaux et
communautaires soit informé et puisse
débattre du rapport relatif à
l'artificialisation des sols et que
cette obligation ne se limite pas dans
les faits au seul
communautaire ces débats ne peuvent être
confisqués par une échelle territoriale
cette modification nous semble donc être
une simple question de démocratie et de
reconnaissance de l'échelon de proximité
qu'est la commune je vous remercie
merci avis de la commission c'est le
président de j'ai pas favorable à ce que
l'exercice soit doublonner de débats de
vote ce sont encore des ordres du jour
des conseils qui seront bloqués en outre
la rédaction de l'article prévoit déjà
que le rapport soit transmis à le pci de
rattachement ou aux communes membres
lorsqu'il est présenté par le pci
l'information sera donc disponible tant
au niveau communal que communautaire
rien n'empêchera le pci de mettre à
l'ordre du jour les rapports de ses
communes membres s'ils le souhaitent ou
vice versa privilégions la souplesse et
mon avis était favorable évidemment je
rejoins l'avis de monsieur le rapporteur
à ceci près que donc même si ces deux
délibérations n'ont pas vocation à ceux
à ceux cumulés et qu elles dépendront de
l'entité qui est compétente soit la
commune en quatre élus ou l'interco en
cas de pluie je crois que ce rapport qui
est présenté dans l'assemblée il
n'empêche en aucun cas les débats et et
à la différence de monsieur le
rapporteur l'inviterai tous les
exécutifs qu'il qu'il juge bon et qui le
souhaitent à se saisir de ces débats
parce qu'il participe je crois de
l'appropriation de ces de ces enjeux en
tout état de cause en tout cas sur cet
amendement c'est un avis défavorable
merci je mets aux voileux 196 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est rejeté deux amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 387
monsieur moreira merci monsieur le
président
chez le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues il s'agit d'un
amendement proposé par notre collègue
nassimah dindar
il vise à exclure les maires et les
présidents des établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale de la
guadeloupe de la martinique de la guyane
de la réunion et de mayotte de
l'obligation d'établissement de rapports
annuels sur l'artificialisation des sols
en effet des territoires ultramarins
accuse un retard conséquent dans
l'établissement des documents de
planification urbaine cette mesure
pourrait freiner davantage que la
construction de logements sociaux et le
2128 n'est pas défendu avis de la
commission sur le 387 sur le président
les départements et régions d'outre-mer
sont en effet confrontées à des enjeux
très particulier en lien avec la
pression foncière le caractère insulaire
les milieux naturels ou encore les
problématiques d'habitat nulle question
de remettre en cause ses spécificités
mais justement il me semble que ces
rapports dont nous avons assoupli la
périodicité en commission permettront
une meilleure connaissance de ces
phénomènes d'artificialisation ils
peuvent offrir l'opportunité de faire
valoir les spécificités ultramarines
comme nous l'avons dit il n'impliqueront
pas une charge mais sera-t-il trop
conséquente pour les collectivités de la
commission donc défavorable ministre je
rejoins monsieur le rapporteur même si
je comprends le message que vous
souhaitez envoyer je crois que justement
à nouveau on a besoin de cette
appropriation de ces enjeux dans le
débat et dans les réflexions et ses
documents de suivi qui constituent aussi
des points de référence dans les
exécutifs des des territoires
ultramarins avec je vous le confirme
donc
une participation de l'observateur du
serena qui sera bien présent dans les
outre mer donc un avis défavorable très
bien donc je mets aux voix le 380 sa
taille deux avis défavorables quai pour
attendait levé clairement la main parce
que c'est un vote un peu curieux de 25
ans qui contre 2,97 baisser la même et
commandé à 17,17 que ça périgueux
certains n'ont pas clairement levé la
main on va leur commencé simplement en
levant la main qui est pour vraiment
levez la main ceux qui sont pour pour de
bon
pif
parce que
avec qui 19 18 mai bc les doigts merci
et qui est contre et merci de lever
franchement lama
il est adopté le 1820 de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
ce président c'est l'amendement de
précision rédactionnelles merci à vis du
gouvernement favorable je mets aux
voileux 1820 avec l'avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté je mets aux voix l'article
50 kg et pour qui est contre il est
adopté l'article 50 bis et supprimer
l'article 51 deux amendements discussion
commune le 197e monsieur varia lahellec
fardeau oui merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la lutte contre l'artificialisation
artificialisation des sols passe
notamment par la limande la limitation
de l'expansion de l'étalement urbain
nous portons donc par cet amendement
l'élargissement de la possibilité
d'imposition d'une densité minimale de
construction particulièrement à
proximité des transports collectifs
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs existants ou à
venir tel est le sens donc de
l'amendement proposé avec la commission
sur le reporter pardon pardon pardon
veut dire d'abord votre amendement 1821
oui il est en discussion commune le 1821
d'abord le 100 97 g président il s'agit
de aujourd'hui d'une faculté à laquelle
les élus locaux peuvent donc recourir ou
non selon les enjeux de densification de
la commune la commission ne souhaite pas
transformer cette faculté en obligations
privilégions une boîte à outils plutôt
qu'une approche coercitives une
densification douce et qualitative
plutôt que quantitative c'est d'ailleurs
la philosophie de l'amendement adopté
par la commission qui crée une telle
faculté dans les zones d'aménagement
concerté avec un avis défavorable et
d'amendements 18 ans 21 de la commission
encore donne deux dispositions miroir du
code de l'urbanisme en commission nous
avons permis aux règlements du pays et
lui d'instaurer des densité minimale au
sein des ac
si les élus le souhaitent par
parallélisme cet amendement précise que
le cahier des charges de zac doit faire
mention de cette densité minimale le cas
échéant merci à vis du gouvernement sur
ces deux amendements en l'état actuel du
droit il est déjà possible effectivement
de fixer cette cette densité minimale
pour les projets qui se développe autour
des transports en commun et puis
toujours en l'état actuel de ce droit le
cahier des charges de cession des lots
d'une zac qui vise à fixer la
constructibilité autorisé encadre déjà
étroitement les projets envisagés en
prévoyant des prescriptions techniques
urbaines et architecturales
il peut donc porter sur la densité des
constructions dans le respect des règles
qui sont fixées par ailleurs dans les
documents d'urbanisme et évidemment les
acteurs de l'aménagement rechercher une
optimisation réel de la densité dans le
cadre d'une opération comme la zac pour
chaque lot commercialisés il me semble
donc pas nécessaire de complexifier ses
dispositions en les rendant obligatoires
pour ce qui est aujourd'hui une
possibilité une faculté pour les
autorités compétentes en matière
d'urbanisme et pour les maîtres
d'ouvragé de zone d'aménagement concerté
et donc c'est un avis défavorable
très bien je mets aux voileux 197 avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui compte il est rejeté le 1821 de la
commission avec un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils étaient de près je mets au voile
article 51 kg et pour qui est contre il
est adopté l'article 51 bis à 1 2144
monsieur marchand
oui monsieur le président l'article
permet de déroger aux règles des plans
locaux d'urbanisme dans les 500 mètres
autour des gares dans les opérations de
revitalisation des territoires
les grandes opérations d'urbanisme les
risques de cet article et qu'il
permettrait un opérateur privé de
déroger elle est dictée par les élus
locaux d'où la demande de suppression de
cet article
merci avis la commission monsieur le
rapporteur c'est le président je suis
entièrement d'accord et le principe
avancé par l'auteur toute dérogation au
pays et l'ue doit expressément être
autorisée par le maire au président de
pci compétent pour délivrer le permis et
le nombre de dérogations doit rester
limitée c'est pourquoi en commission
nous avoir réglé cet article pour
supprimer le passage à un système de
dérogation de droit auquel le maire ne
pourrait que difficilement s'opposer
parti que tel que nous l'examinons
aujourd'hui exige qui désormais la corde
la commune où le pci
en revanche il me semble que la
possibilité de recourir aux dérogations
limitées dans les goûts ou rt et pas
uniquement dans les zones denses et une
bonne chose
en effet les opérations en goût et
surtout en where they peuvent inclure la
de la réhabilitation de la
transformation de bâtiments existants
notamment pour créer du logement
pour cette raison je suis défavorable à
la suppression de cet article
ah oui du gouvernement madame la
ministre l'article 51 bis un tel qu'il
était initialement adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale lui visait à encourager la
densification en zone tendue en
permettant des dérogations
figurant déjà ou pas de l'urbanisme
puisse appliquer par défaut sauf que je
suis motivé dit murray dans des
situations précises et limité l'article
51 bis à tel qu'adopté par la commission
au sénat propose désormais simplement
d'élargir le dispositif dérogatoire
existants au secteur d'intervention
déserté au périmètre des goûts et si
l'article 51 bis à tel que voté par la
commission ne correspond pas à
l'ambition du gouvernement il semble
toutefois qu'il reprenne et renforcent
le droit existant c'est pourquoi je vous
propose le retrait de cet amendement à
défaut j'y serais défavorable
merci et des ruptures discussion commune
le 2168 du gouvernement madame la
ministre je vais prendre un instant si
vous voulez bien monsieur le président
pour vous présenter cet amendement qui
vise à revenir à l'écriture de l'article
51 bis à telle que votée à l'assemblée
nationale je viens de deux d'évoquer ce
que la commission a souhaité en revenant
fonctionnement actuel de ces dérogations
à savoir une obligation de motivation
par le maire de l'autorisation qui elle
délivre alors que nous proposions dans
un premier temps dans certains secteurs
et pour trois types d'opérations que
cette motivation interviennent qu'en cas
de refus
je souhaite rappeler que l'objectif de
notre proposition et qui est de
favoriser les opérations de logements
vertueuses en matière de consommation
d'espacé là où sont les besoins en
termes de logement elle intervient sans
priver les mères de leurs compétences
évidemment la situation actuelle du
secteur de la construction est alarmante
vous le savez l'année 2020 a été
difficile du fait que du confinement
avec 65 mille logements autorisés en
moins par rapport à 2019 et ce sera le
cas aussi malheureusement en 2021
aussi nous agissions avec le pacte pour
la relance de la construction durable
avec la prolongation du pin du pinel et
du ptz avec l'aide d'allah de la relance
de la construction durable sur les huit
premiers mois ce sont plus de 880
communes concernées pour environ 90
millions au total
ainsi que le fonds friche qui est porté
à 650 millions j'ajouterai
les travaux de la commission deux
semaines pour construire mieux nous
devons proposer je crois des solutions
afin de simplifier les procédures et
d'aider les décideurs locaux
nous avons besoin de rendre ce genre de
bonnes pratiques plus simples et les
usages de ce pouvoir de dérogation il
est aujourd'hui complexe et en
définitive très peu utilisé il s'est
donc à travers cet amendement une mesure
qui vise à permettre trois types de
bonnes pratiques la transformation de
bureaux en logements la construction de
logements à proximité des transports en
commun et la construction des tâches
supplémentaires pour les bâtiments
existants dans un système actuel où le
maire doit motiver sa sa décision quand
il autorise une dérogation pour
transformer les bureaux nous proposons
que le maire n'ait plus à justifier de
l'autorisation de ces trois catégories
de bonnes pratiques mais qu'ils
conservent la possibilité évidemment de
s'opposer à de tels projets si ça ne lui
semble pas opportun comme il le fait
classiquement quand il refuse un permis
de construire
merci avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
ce président c'est donc un projet qui
vise à rétablir la version votée par
l'assemblée nationale comme je les dis à
l'amendement précédent la commission est
très défavorable au passage un système
de droit sauf opposition toute
dérogation au pq doit être expressément
autorisée par le maire ou président de
pci compétent pour délivrer les permis
et le nombre de dérogations doit rester
limité la commission et donc défavorable
et souhaite maintenir sa propre
rédaction
merci trois amendements du groupe crc en
discussion commune vous présenter les
trois on est à une minute trente
même pas oui comme vous voulez le
premier 543 c'est la possibilité de
déroger aux règles de gabarit prévue par
la disposition qui se limite à la
surélévation justifiée par la création
de logement ou un agrandissement de
surface giuly serait opportun selon
moudenc l'heure des espaces communs et
ouvrages techniques aux motifs pouvant
ainsi droit à l'application des
dérogations sur le deuxième sur le
président on trouve difficilement
compréhensible que la nouvelle rédaction
de cet article introduit un
élargissement de la dérogation à ses
servitudes de mixité sociale à toutes
les opérations de transformation d'un
immeuble existant dont est déjà un usage
principal d'habitation alors que dans sa
rédaction actuelle
sa portée est limitée à la
transformation des usages d'immeubles
existants afin de les destiner à un
usage d'habitation qui n'étaient pas
prêts existants et le troisième est un
amendement de repli qui vise à rétablir
l'intention initiale du législateur je
vous remercie très bien avec la
commission sur ces 3 1 en main deux
amants n'auront donc 3 3 et 143 544 545
alors 543 vise à préciser monsieur
présent que les opérations de création
d'un grandissement de logements qui
peuvent bénéficier des dérogations
incluent celles qui modifie les parties
communes de ces logements ou leur
équipement par exemple cuisine comme une
buanderie ventilation et les organismes
de logement social notamment nous ont
indiqué que cette précision était
nécessaire l'avis est favorable tout en
rappelant que c'est la commune où le pci
qui choisira ou non d'octroyer les
dérogations le 544 opère plusieurs
modifications entre autres supprime la
possibilité pour les projets de
transformation de bâtiments logements de
déroger exceptionnellement aux règles
mixité sociale je rappelle que nous
avions collectivement voter cette
dérogation lors de l'examen de la loi et
l'an 2018 la transformation des
bâtiments prêts existants un pic de
travailler qu'un volume des espaces un
gabarit et des conditions prédéterminées
peut donc concerner deux petits
bâtiments appliquer les plus tôt de
logement social sur de si petites
opérations ne se justifie pas et serait
contre productive pour les opérations de
transformation en outre cette dérogation
est octroyée par la commune le pci si
jamais l'élu estime que les taux de
logement social doivent s'appliquer et
sont pertinents il peut être il peut
très facilement refuser la dérogation je
rappelle aussi que cette dérogation aux
règles mixité sociale ne peut pas être
délivré dans les communes carencée en
logement social c'est donc un avis
défavorable en revanche la commission
est tout à fait favorable à l'amendement
au moment de répit 545 qui corrige une
erreur de rédaction à vis du
gouvernement sur ces trois amendements
ministre sur l'assassin sur les 543 qui
élargit les dérogations règle gabarit
pour la création des espaces communs
j'ai le même avec monsieur le rapporteur
avec sur le fond des dérogations prévues
à l'article 152 6 du code de l'urbanisme
qui vise à permettre la production de
logements en améliorant les équilibres
économiques d'opérations vertueuse mais
qui sont plus coûteuses et complexes
c'est donc une une demande de retrait ça
des faux avis défavorable puisque la
création de ces espaces communs et ses
bâtiments techniques ne me paraît pas
justifié un bonus de constructibilité
ils relèvent de choix constructifs et du
fonctionnement de ces bâtiments et et le
chant de l'application de cet amendement
me paraît beaucoup trop large sur les
questions de règles de mixité sociale
avec la dérogation qui est déjà présente
en la matière dans l'article 152 6 qui
actuellement en vigueur dans le code de
l'urbanisme
nous avons donc dans des communes non
car anciens logements sociaux la
facilité de transformer des immeubles
par exemple de bureaux en logements et
ne me semble donc pas opportun de
supprimer comme vous le proposez 7
cette dérogation avec sur le deuxième
point de l'amendement la possibilité de
régler un problème rédactionnel en
revenant l'écriture actuelle en vigueur
dans le code de l'urbanisme et votre
amendement 545 règle ce même problème
rédactionnelle et je privilégierai pré
qualif privilégierait donc donc en
donnant un avis favorable aux 545
rectifier très bien aller nous mettons
voie monsieur guépard dont juste au
maintien de 543 et on retire le 544 au
profil 545 très bien alors je mets
d'abord on voit le 2168 du gouvernement
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est pour
pas très clair ce créneau qui l'est puis
rabaissé la main levé la main qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 543 favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté le 5 145 avec deux avis
favorables qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est adopté je mets aux voileux 51 bis
à quai pour qui est contre il est adopté
après l'article 51 bis à le 8 160
l'amendement 877 le président longeau
l'amendement de madame loisy le respect
de certaines normes de construction
faisant preuve d' exemplarité
environnementale implique une
augmentation de l'épaisseur de certains
éléments du bâtiment
ceci augmente la hauteur des étages et
peut poser des difficultés dans le cas
de plans locaux d'urbanisme qui
contraignent les auteurs autorisé
aujourd'hui le code de l'urbanisme ne
permet pas le déplacement hauteur pour
les constructions innovantes par rapport
aux constructions traditionnelles sans
modification du p lus et intégration
d'une clause spécifique
il s'agit donc de donner la possibilité
de déroger aux règles de hauteur que le
dispositif de construction nécessite une
hauteur plus importante d'un procédé
traditionnel tel est le fond de cet
amendement merci à vis de la commission
le président les nouvelles exigences de
la et revin en matière de performance
environnementale des constructions
impliquera un recours plus important aux
constructions en bois or dans certains
cas les règles de hauteur des pme ne
permettent pas d'autoriser les
charpentes en bois dont le gabarit et
puis qu'on sait conséquent pour les
bâtiments environnants si l'on veut
commencer dès aujourd'hui la transition
de la filière bâtiment et encourager
l'utilisation de matériaux biosourcés
dans la construction il est pertinent de
faire des dérogations limitées aux
règles des pl us et donc la commission y
est favorable
sa vidéo la ministre je vous rejoins
tout à fait monsieur le président dans
cette volonté d'encourager la
construction qui fait preuve d'
exemplarité environnementale est en
parfaite cohérence avec l'objectif de
cette loi
concrètement les planchers d'un immeuble
avec une structure en bois doivent avoir
une épaisseur plus importante que des
planchers en béton pour obtenir les
mêmes performances acoustiques
énergétique ces exigences elles seront
accentués dans le cadre de la r 20 et
dans certains cas la règle de hauteur
maximale qui est définie par le ps
pourrait donc contraindre la
construction en bois avoir un nombre
d'états inférieur à celui d'une
construction
doté d'une structure plus classique cela
peut nuire effectivement la vie à billy
économique des projets mais aussi à
l'objectif de densité qui est fixé par
le pea lui avec cette difficulté qui se
rencontrent de plus en plus sur le
terrain et cet amendement qui permet
donc de résoudre en autorisant des
dérogations aux règles de hauteur du pmu
dans cette situation et à nombre
d'étagés évidemment constance sans
exiger la révision préalable du
préalable du pmu c'est donc un avis très
favorable
très bien je vais donc mettre aux voix
le 877 avec un avis favorable et un avis
très favorable qu'est pour qui est
contre il est adopté à l'article 51 bis
b en 2169 du gouvernement madame la
ministre
oui monsieur le président donc cet
amendement il a pour objet de soumettre
certains projets au moyen d'une
procédure adaptée et en raison de leur
dimensionnement une déclaration
préalable en lieu et place d'un permis
de construire alors l'objectif
d'accélération et de simplification en
faveur de la relance et de la
construction qui est proposée par
l'article 51 bis b l'introduit
il a été par par votre commission
néanmoins cet article il prévoit un
dispositif qui est déjà satisfait par le
droit existant en effet les travaux sur
constructions existantes sont déjà
soumis par principe à une déclaration
préalable
je suis également favorable à un
élargissement du champ de la déclaration
préalable pour réduire les délais sur
les projets les plus simples mais à
condition d'en garantir la qualité
enfin ces dispositions les en vocation à
s'appliquer de façon uniforme sur tout
le territoire sous peine de créer une
incertitude sur le droit applicable par
les pétitionnaires et donc se présente
amendement il propose de mettre en place
un régime dérogatoire est limitée dans
le temps qui permette aux pétitionnaires
de voir son projet relever du régime
moins contraignant de la déclaration
préalable au lieu du permis construire
dans un objectif de simplification et de
relance de la construction
merci à vis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur le président c'est un
amendement qui élargit le dispositif
expérimental en effet en ne limitant pas
à la rénovation et la réhabilitation en
eau qui renvoie de nombreux paramètres
un décret en conseil d'état enfin il
supprime les dispositions visant à
garantir que ces expérimentations soit
instaurée à l'initiative des communes
qu'il ose qui le souhaitent
en outre il supprime le caractère
expérimental de la démarche et la
commission y est défavorable en revanche
nous sommes tout à fait disposés à
travailler que madame la ministre d'ici
la commission mixte paritaire pour en
affiner la rédaction et aboutir au
meilleur ciblage
merci je mets au voile de le 2169 du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté je mets nouveau à
l'article 51 bis b qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est adopté
[Musique]